you know i have to say i think one of
the features you know when we look at
uh sort of today from the future so to
speak
i suspect one of the things where people
will say i can't believe they didn't see
that
is stuff to do with the following kind
of thing so so
you know if we describe oh i don't know
something like
um heat for instance we say oh
you know the air in in here it's you
know it's this temperature this pressure
that's as much as we can say otherwise
just a bunch of random molecules
bouncing around
people will say i just can't believe
they didn't realize that there was all
this detail and how all these molecules
were bouncing around
and they could make use of that i mean
actually i realized there's a thing i
realized last week actually
was um was the thing that people say you
know one of the scenarios for the very
long term history of our universe
is the so-called heat death of the
universe where basically
everything just becomes
thermodynamically boring
everything's just this big kind of gas
and thermal equilibrium people say
that's a really bad outcome
but actually it's not a really bad
outcome it's an outcome where there's
all this computation going on and all
those individual gas molecules are all
bouncing around in very complicated ways
doing this very elaborate computation
it just happens to be a computation that
right now we haven't found
ways to understand we haven't found ways
you know our brains haven't
you know and our mathematics and our
science and so on haven't found
ways to tell an interesting story about
that it just looks boring to us
there's a there you're saying there's a
hopeful view
of the he-death quote-unquote of the
universe where there's actual
beautiful complexity what's going on
similar to
the kind of complexity we think of
that creates rich experience in human
life and life on earth yes
so those little molecules interact in
complex ways that
that could be intelligence in that there
could be absolutely i mean this this is
this is what you learn from this
hopeful message right i mean this is
what you kind of learn from this
principle of computational equivalence
you learn it's both a a message of
of sort of hope and a message of kind of
you know there's you're not as special
as you think you are so to speak i mean
because you know we
we imagine that with sort of all the
things we do with with human
intelligence and all that kind of thing
and all of the stuff we've constructed
in science it's like
we're very special but actually it turns
out well
no we're not we're just doing
computations like
things in nature do computations like
those gas molecules do computations like
the weather does computations
the only the only thing about the
computations that we do that's really
special
is that we understand what they are so
to speak in other words
we have a you know to us they're special
because kind of they're connected to our
purposes our ways of thinking about
things and so on
and that's some but so so that's very
human-centric that's we're just
attached to this kind of thing
you